[Music]
on this monday night who hacked a vital
pipeline
the ransomware attack that choked off
the flow of fuel and
spurred an emergency order from the
white house these groups are realizing
that by targeting industrial companies
they get higher payouts what lessons can
canada learn to keep critical
infrastructure and companies safe
gunned down at vancouver airport what's
behind a rash
of recent shootings this generation of
gangsters is
taking things to another level plus hold
on tight
the tourists trapped high up in high
winds
and making a match it was surreal it was
absolutely
phenomenal a sailor from the doomed
franklin expedition is for the first
time
linked to his descendant
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the brazen cyber attack
that has shut down the biggest pipeline
in the united states cutting off the
flow of gasoline
diesel and jet fuel today the fbi put
out a statement pointing the finger at a
group of hackers
the fbi says the dark side ransomware is
responsible for the compromise
of the colonial pipeline networks the
hack shut down its entire network friday
afternoon
today the company said it hopes to be
back online by the end of the week
the colonial pipeline supplies fuel from
the gulf coast to the densely populated
eastern
and southern united states darkside
is a known organized group of hackers
mostly based in russia
it claims it targets profitable private
companies and that its goal
is to make money not create problems for
society
in the us most critical infrastructure
is owned by private companies and what's
happened reveals the reach
and the destabilizing power of
ransomware attacks
jackson proskow has our top story
tonight
four days after the hack this critical
supply of u.s energy remains at a
standstill
interrupting the daily flow of two and a
half million barrels of diesel
gasoline and jet fuel nearly half the
supply of the u.s east coast
it's still the first and largest
major disruption of energy
infrastructure in the united states that
is coming from a cyber problem
on friday hackers broke into colonial
pipelines business operations and
launched a ransomware attack
the company shut down the pipeline to
protect the rest of its computers
the fbi says a russian cyber gang called
darkseid is to blame
it's not clear if the action was state
sponsored at this time we assess
that darkseid is a criminal actor but
that's certainly something
that our intelligence community is
looking into ransomware attacks are
typically about
money not disruption hackers encrypt the
victim's computer files so they can't be
accessed
and demand a hefty payment to unlock
them these groups are realizing
that by targeting industrial companies
they get higher payouts
and the companies are more willing to
pay out because they want to return
these vital
operations the u.s is reeling from a
string of more traditional cyber attacks
that have exposed vulnerabilities
a water treatment plant in florida was
hacked in what's believed to have been
an attempt to poison the water supply
and the us government is still assessing
the damage from the massive solar winds
data breach
experts see what happened to colonial as
a warning
one could with the malicious intent
turn a routine piece of energy
infrastructure
into a weapon even if the colonial hack
was just about money it could cause
price hikes and supply shortages if it
drags on
it's not known how much money the
hackers wanted or if colonial paid the
ransom to unlock its computers
officially the white house says it's not
getting involved because the hack
involves a private company
donna all right jackson thanks well no
one knows for sure how often ransoms are
paid
but it's believed about 18 billion
dollars was paid around the world last
year
in canada it's estimated 797 million
dollars was paid
in 2020. ransom demands have increased
significantly in this country
as michael couture explains attackers
are also becoming more and more
sophisticated they probably picked the
worst day in our company's history to
you know to try and hold us ransom jan
gritskovich and his team were about to
submit
the largest bid in the company's history
on the morning of april 16th his
employees logged on
and realized there was a serious problem
with their computer system
this cell came up and basically said
you've been hacked
if you want to you know collect your
information basically
here's our email address they never
responded and never found out
how much the hackers wanted regular
backups of their system helped save most
of the information but the delay in
submitting that bid
may have cost them a multi-million
dollar contract
and cyber security specialists say the
timing of that attack
was likely well planned wouldn't be
atypical for an attacker to understand
be reading your email watching your
network activity
and waiting for the moment where it's
going to be most painful for you
before implementing the ransomware
andrew loschman says hackers are no
longer just
kids in their parents basements their
sophisticated organizations
targeting companies and sometimes
schools
in 2016 the university of calgary was
one of hundreds of institutions
targeted by malware administrators paid
the 23 thousand dollars ransom
after realizing the files being held
hostage were way too valuable
people's lives work were on those
desktops those laptops and those servers
and to compromise someone's life work
we just weren't willing to take that
risk the fbi eventually charged two men
in iran for the university of calgary
attack but there will
always be others so much of our
infrastructure in this country
is computerized or digital some warn our
public institutions
are vulnerable they quite often can't
afford the
resources so that quite often you'll see
a gap in that area where
public sector maybe isn't as well
protected as private sector now experts
say cyber criminals are always looking
for the
easiest target and the best way to
protect yourself
is to increase your cyber security to
make it harder for hackers to get in
mike liquiter global news ottawa
in british columbia a gang war is
escalating into a series of targeted
shootings including one yesterday
afternoon at vancouver international
airport when the police pursued the
suspect
shots were fired at them too there have
been about a dozen
shootings many in public places in the
last two weeks
as robin gill reports they involve three
key gangs and a new generation
of gangsters vancouver international
airport is a very public place
but that didn't stop the guns from
coming out on sunday afternoon
a known gangster was killed this
generation of gangsters
is taking things to another level which
is having no regard
whatsoever with community safety
the police tried to pursue the suspected
murderers but they got aggressive
and fired at officers then
in what's become a typical scene the
getaway vehicle was torched
police believe 28 year old carmen
garewal a member of the united nations
gang
with a criminal record was killed in
retaliation for the death of another
gangster
these gang conflicts have continued
there's been more and more
groups being formed which has resulted
in more conflict
in the vancouver area three gangs
dominate the united nations
the brothers keepers and the red
scorpions but allegiances constantly
change and new criminal organizations
are formed according to bc's anti-gang
police unit
they all have one goal these individuals
make no mistake about it are vying for
control of the drug trade
that turf war has led to a rise in
shootings in the past two weeks
on saturday outside a shop with
surveillance cameras
a gunman shot and killed a 19 year old
with gang ties
another person who just happened to be
in the area also took a bullet
but survived a week earlier a
corrections officer
bikram deep rundawa was gunned down
outside a mall
but that's a mystery because he isn't
affiliated with any criminals
we're at a crisis point right now and
unfortunately
and i hope my predictions don't come to
reality that there's other innocent
people that are going to be caught in
this crossfire
it's obvious these criminals have no
concern for public safety
the shooting at vancouver airport was a
blatantly violent act
for anyone to witness robin gill global
news vancouver
now to the pandemic though vaccinations
are increasing millions of canadians are
under tight public health restrictions
because cases
are still rising in several provinces
nova scotia reported more than 120 new
infections today its borders are now
closed to all non-essential travel
in manitoba bars and restaurants are
closed in-person dining
schools in winnipeg and brandon moved to
online learning on wednesday
and in alberta restaurants are now
takeout or delivery only
alberta still has by far the most active
cases per capita
570 infections per 100 000 people
that's more than double manitoba which
is the next hardest hit province per
capita
despite the alarming trends
anti-lockdown protesters gathered again
in alberta over the weekend today the
leader of the federal ndp
said there are parallels to those
protests
and far-right extremism to
brazenly not follow public health
guidelines put people puts people at
risk
and that is that is something that we've
seen with extreme right-wing
ideology putting people at risk not
being concerned about the safety of
others
not being concerned about the welfare of
others there is a connection certainly
alberta's justice minister is refusing
to apologize after suggesting the media
the federal government and others want
alberta's health care system to collapse
casey madhu made the comment on facebook
while defending his government's
latest restrictions he said i don't
think it will be responsible to simply
wait until we have a disaster on our
hands
that's what the ndp the media and the
federal liberals
were looking for and want we simply
couldn't allow that to happen
when asked about that comment madhu's
press secretary said he was
referring to the increasing tendency of
different groups including the ndp
to exploit the pandemic for their own
political purposes the minister
won't apologize for stating the obvious
today alberta became the first province
to start booking a covid 19 vaccinations
for anyone age 12 and up
and by 12 pm today the premier said
more than 72 thousand people had booked
their shots
ontario is also expanding its vaccine
eligibility
starting thursday people 40 and older
can book their first shot
the province is also making it easier
for some essential workers to get
vaccinated
the ontario food terminal in toronto
became the latest workplace to get its
own on-site vaccination clinic
it is the largest produce distribution
center in canada
dozens of its workers were infected
during an outbreak
last month and some good news today for
high-risk health care workers in ontario
they have been added to the list of
people who won't have to wait four
months for their second dose
among those eligible are hospital and
acute care staff in front line roles
paramedics and other medical first
responders and long-term care workers
bookings for the second dose will open
by the end of this week
despite the progress with vaccinations
ontarians are being warned the covet
situation is still precarious
and the provincial stay-at-home order
set to expire next week will likely be
extended while it may feel like there's
no end to the crisis
what's happening now in the uk is a
source of some optimism
for the first time in many months
england reported zero deaths from covet
19 today
scotland and northern ireland also
reported no new deaths
with infection rates falling and
vaccination numbers climbing
new freedoms are finally on the way
crystal gomencing explains
[Music]
it's not every day you see a dancing
bear on the streets of london
but this was no ordinary day
boris johnson said the words people have
been waiting
months to hear we've met our four tests
for further easing the lockdown in
england
this unlocking amounts to a very
considerable step on the road back
to normality starting may 17th people
will no longer be forced to sit outside
to have a meal with a few friends
indoor dining will be added to the menu
along with
movies overnight hotel stays and
sporting events
all things banned in england since
before
christmas threats are significantly
reduced but there are still some
residual issues i'm going to be doing
our vaccinations more than 35 million
people have had at least
one shot of a covet 19 vaccine officials
say that has directly reduced
deaths by up to 80 percent and has
reduced hospitalization
up to 85 percent the extended
lockdown contained the spread of the
virus while buying
time to boost vaccination numbers just
like at the start of the lockdown
england's chief medical officer says the
issue of concern
remains virus variants we have
a concern at the moment about a variant
called b1617.2 rather snappy
name first described from india and
this is actually spreading from very
small amounts
still the experts support the reopening
so much so that physical contact
including hugs
are also set to make a comeback whoever
i
hug i can assure you will be done with
caution and uh and restraint
uh i'm not going to to you know act it
out now
no hugs for the camera from the prime
minister at least
not yet england is on track for all
restrictions to be removed
by june twenty first crystal commansing
global news
london rocket attacks and airstrikes in
israel coming up what's triggered some
of the worst violence in a long time
between israelis
and palestinians
[Music]
the violence and counter-attacks are
escalating in israel tonight israel's
prime minister who has failed to form a
coalition after a fourth election
is talking tough again and launching
airstrikes on gaza
after hamas fired rockets at israel
gaza's health ministry says 20 people
are dead
including three children and there is
fury among palestinians after israeli
police stormed the al-aqsa mosque in
jerusalem
redmond shannon reports and a warning
his story contains
disturbing images
more anguish and now more death
a scene all too familiar here and sadly
almost
inevitable where a series of events have
brought tensions
to boiling point
following days of violence in jerusalem
more confrontations
early monday hundreds were injured in
clashes with israeli police
at the alaska mosque islam's third
holiest site
sitting on judaism's sacred temple mount
worshipers stayed after morning prayers
to defend the mosque against a march of
jewish activists marking jerusalem day
the anniversary of israel's annexation
of the east of the city
the march was monday was also a day
where an israeli court was due to hear
the case of the proposed eviction of
palestinian families
in the nearby sheikh jarrah neighborhood
the hearing was postponed
i think the temple mount is the place
where
nationalism and religion meet this
applies to jews
as well as muslims and it's a tinderbox
to put it bluntly
some zionist israeli lawmakers headed
into sheikh jarrah
ramping up tensions further they don't
accept the fact the jews
can be can go and on their holiest site
the temple mount we are standing with
palestinian family
in gerard against
the evacuation plan and then
later in the day rockets fired from gaza
toward jerusalem
leading to israeli air strikes in
response killing gazans
including children and a hamas commander
at a jerusalem day event israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu warned
the current confrontation may last a
while
this latest crisis arguably a political
gift for the longtime leader
facing corruption charges and clinging
on to power after
another inconclusive election redmond
shannon global news
london ahead
horrifying heights a tourist looking to
walk on air gets more than he bargained
for you're watching global national
if you're afraid of heights this would
be your worst nightmare this tourist in
northern china ended up clean to the
railing of a
meter high suspension bridge gale force
winds had shattered the glass panels on
the bridge
it happened on friday apparently he was
stuck there for 30 minutes before he was
rescued
i guess you wouldn't be on that bridge
if you had a fear of heights right
in eastern china a zoo is apologizing
for not alerting the public for weeks
after three of its leopards escaped the
alarm was eventually raised by residents
who spotted the big cats
surveillance cameras caught the leopards
roaming the streets of a residential
area search teams eventually found two
of them one is still on the loose
the animal park says they didn't report
the missing leopards because they didn't
want to trigger
panic a criminal investigation is
underway
up next science meets history how
genetics helped unearth a long-lost
sailor's past
there is a new intriguing connection to
a story that has fascinated the world
since the 1800s
one of the crew members from the
franklin expedition that failed mission
to find the northwest passage
has been identified and matched to one
of his descendants who is alive today
it is the first time such a connection
has been made and it's helping bring
alive the story of what's believed to be
the greatest loss of life in the history
of polar exploration eric sorenson
explains
it is one of the enduring sagas of the
arctic the unimaginable ordeal for the
130 crew members of the franklin
expedition
the hms erebus was discovered underwater
just seven years ago
and hms terror two years later but the
remains of crew members had been found
over many decades by the inuit
and later came scientists this is a
story of human endeavor
douglas stenton is an anthropologist
whose team set out to find who these men
were
and what they did the dna analysis and
these sorts of things provide a new lens
in a sense for us to try and understand
more about what happened
it was an expedition through the
northwest passage in search of the
pacific
the two ships terror and erebus made it
as far as king william island
and became stuck in ice in 1846 the
ships were found just a few years ago
much further south
but in 1848 after two winters and still
ice bound
the crew headed out on foot remains were
discovered along the coast of the island
some made it to the mainland the remains
at arabis bay
would be a breakthrough stenton's team
gathered samples from 27 crew members
then dna tests from 17 modern
descendants
they got one match this is the skull of
warrant officer
john gregory and a conception of what he
looked like in life
and this is jonathan gregory a
descendant in south africa
who sent his dna sample to canada then
heard back just last month
we have a positive dna match and i
literally had to hold on to my seat
you know it was it was surreal it was
it was absolutely phenomenal just as
delighted
scientists at the dna lab in thunder bay
definitely
felt good that we had actually made a
match after all this time
it's just a small piece of information
to the big mystery surrounding what
happened there is much that remains a
mystery around those fateful years in
the arctic
but one family now knows that a direct
relative survived for three years in the
arctic
and they know that he didn't die alone
there were there were the remains of two
other men
found at this site to be a gregory to be
jonathan gregory linked to john gregory
it's an important
day for our family gregory says it
brings his family closer to their
ancestors
scientists hope it's just the first dna
match that they'll find other relatives
and learn more about franklin's men and
what they endured more than 170 years
ago
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is queen's park in toronto
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]